it's a program a loser a pro Barama a
probe all you can probe buffet rather
than legislate both parties in
Washington want to investigate the
misdeeds of the other with just a few
weeks left of their majority House
Republicans want to hold hearings on the
Clinton Foundation meanwhile Democrats
now under new investigation looking at
Ivanka Trump's use of a private email to
carry out government business they want
to equate Ivanka to Hillary Clinton and
her private server but the president
says there's no comparison Ivanka can
handle herself these are all in the
historical records there was no deletion
whatsoever
unlike Hillary Clinton who deleted
33,000 emails
unlike Hillary Clinton who had a server
in the basement the Warka didn't
business just early on when she came in
these calls were not classified
unlike Hillary Clinton's calls which
were classified and it's all fake news
there was the president before his
Thanksgiving break Brandon Wright is a
Democrat and former CIA officer Brian we
have court houses legislating and we
have legislators holding trials is this
the best use of Congress oh we've got
two years of this brother
I hope we're all ready there's your
answer is no look there is a small
degree of oversight that is critical but
that both the Senate and the house do so
whether it's looking into the Hillary
Clinton Foundation Bill and Hillary
Clinton Foundation all those shenanigans
let the Department of Justice wrap that
up you know only Ivanka side let's make
sure she didn't send any classified but
at the end of the day you know how many
people really care about Ivanka's emails
absent classified information not many
in fact I'm going to go ahead and say
none you know I'm in northern Indiana
and I can guarantee you that the people
in Fort Wayne places like Huntington
aren't concerned with Ivanka's emails
it's just not the right way to govern
because they're not interested in all
that silliness what do they want they
want the Congress to focus on the stuff
that they're supposed to focus on jobs
health care those are the things that
America cares about you
you're not gonna get anywhere on that
though are you because basically the
energy in the New Democrat Congress is
for well for sup there's a lot of people
who want to impeach the president and if
they can't impeach the president they'd
at least like to end snare those around
him such as members of his family in
tedious investigations for a couple of
years sure look we've seen this right
for the past 20 plus years what what
really what is America experienced one
side trying to mess over the other with
the hope that they can gain even greater
power in the next election and I think
what you have seen certainly in 2016 and
a degree here in the last few weeks is
people walking in to the voting booth
and using their middle finger to vote
and saying enough let's get back to the
business of governing and I think most
people are so frustrated by the
back-and-forth of not solving problems
again Huntington I'll give you a great
example the the carrier company shut
down and is laid off a whole bunch of
folks are they caring about Ivanka's
emails no they're not they don't want
good jobs they want to solve this this
global trade issue where everything's
get shipped off to Mexico or to China
that's the stuff that people care about
good health care so if people don't get
the results they want either from this
last election when Democrats won or
President Trump and his promises in 2016
parties are gonna pay for it somebody's
gonna have to pay for it and you watch
they will is there a serious structural
problem here that the Democrats
particularly but you could make you can
make points about both sides on this in
effect the criminalization of politics
so that if you have a particular
approach to immigration or health care
or whatever it is it's it's not just
that you have a public policy difference
it's that in some sense you're a
criminal and you have to be investigated
right well when you see the other side
is evil that's when you start getting
this investigative junk and so we have
to change that with our own hearts and
definitely when we go to the voting
booth we have to forward prospects of
folks in political system who are more
interested in
problems and not seeing the other side
is evil I mean that's really what it
comes down to okay Bryan we'll we'll
wait and see whether they take you at
your word for that thanks sir for that
have a good Thanksgiving yeah